hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe
I'm your host Ron Carol and I'm wearing
what apparently is going to be the
uniform for what I wear when we're doing
green screen work it turns out
experimentation has taught me that
wearing red things makes it especially
easy to remove the green from the
background if you watched the Q&A video
that we just released sometimes there's
an extra flaw in the green screen namely
that the cats play with it but hopefully
we can avoid that this time so the
subject matter for this particular video
the last one we did number one was
called conservation and we basically
talked about motion but motion that was
in a straight line at a constant
velocity so today we're tackling change
now of course this is an overly broad
word to be talking about so what
specifically do I mean when I have
change in mind of course if something is
moving even at a straight line at
constant velocity that's still change in
the uniform but it would be a very
boring universe if that's all that ever
happened for an interesting universe
what you want is things bumping into
each other things being pushed around
things being forced to change how they
are moving so what we're going to go
into a little bit is some of the ideas
behind what we know is classical
mechanics ok Newtonian mechanics
remember F equals MA this is one of the
most important equations in physics
force equals mass times acceleration if
you're moving at a constant velocity and
the velocity is never changing because
you're not being affected by anything
the acceleration is zero any deviation
from that is acceleration and it's
caused in the Newtonian world by forces
however there's a way to actually figure
out what happens when you have those
forces and that way is called calculus
so really even though I titled the video
change most of what we're talking about
it will be calculus the mathematical
technique for studying not just change
in general but continuous change in
particular now why would I not just call
the video calculus you know change is a
little bit of a sexier name right you
can run for president with the motto of
seeking tain
no one's gonna run for president with
the motto of seeking calculus but
calculus is the mathematical idea behind
the accumulation of gradual continuous
change over time so we're gonna have to
dig into that just a little bit so but
before we actually dig into it let's see
where we were so Newton right 1600s
Newton by the way I'm sure you've heard
this million times already Newton did
most of his brilliant scientific and
mathematical work during a quarantine
during a lockdown there was the black
plague that was going through Europe and
Cambridge University was shut down
Newton had to go home and he invented
what we now know as classical mechanics
so I'm not quite up to that standard but
I can talk about what Newton invented
during our own little lockdown here one
of the things that Newton knew about one
of the empirical pieces of information
he had was from Kepler right Johannes
Kepler was the astronomer I think I
guess today we call him a theoretical
astrophysicist but he was the one who
figured out that planets move in
ellipses he had three laws in fact
Kepler I can never remember them so I
looked them up so one is that planets
moving around the Sun move in ellipses
rather than in circles so before Kepler
came along we had a controversy a
conversation between Copernicus and
Ptolemy okay Ptolemy said that the earth
was at the center of the solar system
and the Sun and all the other planets
moved around it to fit the data which
Ptolemy was interested in doing it
wasn't that the Sun and the other
planets moved around the earth in
perfect circles there was a big circle
and there's a little epicyclic circle
there were tiny little circles around
which the planets moved and the center
of the epicyclic circles would move
around the big circle and it became a
terrible mess and you might say well
people should just thrown that away and
gone with the Sun being at the center of
the universe earlier so Copernicus did
that Copernicus said okay the Sun is at
the center of the solar system but it
turns out that even that doesn't fit the
data in fact it doesn't fit the data
nearly as well as Ptolemy's system did
unless you also have epicycles in your
heliocentric Copernican system so
Copernicus said fine we'll have
epicycles Ptolemy had them why not it
was Kepler who said that
throw away the epicycles we don't need
epicycles circles moving on circles
moving on circles to explain the motion
of the planets there's a much easier way
to do it an ellipse you've seen pictures
of ellipses it's basically like a
squashed circle there you go program is
able to do it and Kepler said that the
Sun is that one of the foci foci focuses
of the ellipse and the planet will move
around the ellipse like that that was
rule number one first law of Kepler's
laws but then he went beyond that this
was a very important law but then he
became quantitative about it okay it's
not just that they move in ellipses but
he says equal areas are swept out by the
planet in equal times so what does that
mean it means you know if you're far
away from the Sun then for every given
angle that you move around you sweep out
a certain area if you're close to the
Sun you need to sweep out a much bigger
angle to get the same area in your
motion okay the area is just the area of
the swept out line between the Sun and
the planet so Kepler said that as the
planet moves around it's going to sweep
out an equal amount of area in an equal
amount of time I have no idea how we
figured this out this is quite a subtle
little quantitative law here but what it
means in practice is that when you're
near the Sun you move faster right
because you're otherwise sweeping out
less area per unit distance so your time
has to be such that you move faster more
distance in the same amount of time
whereas when you're far away from the
Sun you can move more slowly a very
rigorous precise quantitative relation
and finally another quantitative
relation the period the time it takes
the planet to go all the way around the
ellipse squared is proportional to the
axis the semi-major axis which you can
think of roughly as the radius the
distance very well
speaking cubed okay the period of the
planet going around the Sun is
proportional to the semi-major axis
cubed
no we're not gonna go into any details
here that's why I'm not being too
specific but these are Kepler's three
laws and it was controversial but the
idea of ellipses and these beautiful
quantitative laws was certainly much
more elegant and simple than all the
epicycles that Copernicus or Ptolemy
could have posted of so people like
Galileo were big fans big boosters of
Kepler and by the time Newton came along
I think the people more or less
understood this was what was going on
however what you can perceive by
thinking about these rules is that they
kind of work one planet at a time right
there's no mechanism beneath this you
just state as a law planets move in
ellipses equal areas are swept out in
equal times and so forth you might want
to know why that is true and furthermore
if you think that the thing that is
keeping the planet moving around the Sun
is the force of gravity as was not
necessarily clear to people like
Copernicus and Kepler who maybe thought
that there were celestial spheres and
there was something that was just
inherent in the nature of the motion of
the planets but if you think is gravity
then you might think well mostly the
planet moves around the Sun but a planet
like the earth is also going to be
affected by the motion of the other
planets there will also be perturbations
tiny little influences from things like
Jupiter and Mars and Venus and so maybe
this idea of planets moving around in
ellipses is just a good approximation
maybe this is the spherical cow of solar
system astronomy by the way something I
wanted to mention here is that Kepler
really was a theoretical astrophysicist
the data that he used to derive these
laws was mostly collected by Tycho Brahe
he who was a Danish astronomer who was
Kepler's mentor in some sense in some
very real sense this was the first
astronomical theory of the big data era
- Kepler working in the 1500s or the
1600s
Tycho's observations would have
represented what we would now call big
data just big collections like
Oh didn't even have a telescope he just
looked in very very carefully figured
out where on the sky each planet was at
every different moment and from that
Kepler was able to abstract these laws
okay but by the time Newton comes around
do you think this is probably just the
result of some more fundamental
underlying mechanism so what was that
mechanism that was the force of gravity
there's of course a story of Newton
during this lockdown when he went home
from Cambridge University seeing an
Apple fall from a tree this is a story
told by Newton by the way Newton liked a
sort of brush up his image a little bit
he tells the story of seeing the Apple
fall from the tree he didn't invent
gravity people knew the apples held from
trees long before Newton came along and
they knew that it was because of gravity
that apples fell from trees what
Newton's insight really was is that the
force of gravity is universal that the
same force that is making the Apple fall
from the tree is also explaining how the
planets move so it's really universal
gravity the Newton added to the game and
he added it with some equations so
Newton said that the force due to
gravity it's really a vector but I'm
going to ignore all those complications
is proportional so there's some constant
of proportionality which we call
Newton's constant capital G for gravity
the mass of one object times the mass of
the other object divided by R squared R
is just the distance between them so
this is the inverse square law of
gravity you don't need to remember any
of this none of the equations that I
ever write down here are crucial parts
of what we're talking about the point is
the force decreases as the distance
increases as R gets bigger and bigger R
squared is what is proportional to the
total force of gravity who cares
who knows what this is supposed to tell
us about the motion of the planets well
Newton also came up with Newton's second
law F equals M a where a is the
acceleration of the object being acted
on
and together these two laws so you have
the Sun you have a planet the Sun has a
gravitational force capital M is the
mass of the Sun little M is the mass of
the planet R is the distance between
them you can figure out the force acted
on the planet by the Sun the Sun is
pulling the planet toward it okay this
is how much force there is what does the
force do Newton says it accelerates the
particle the object the planet in this
case so without the acceleration the
planet would just move on a straight
line at constant velocity that's
conservation of momentum but because
it's not a closed system because it's
being acted on by an external force it
accelerates the velocity changes
acceleration is just the rate of change
of the velocity so as last time what I
care about here is less solving some
equations and getting some details with
really appreciating the philosophical
underpinnings of what's going on here
the deep meaning of what we're seeing at
work okay if you have a law that just
says in vacuum everything moves at a
constant velocity that's great if you
have a law that says planets move around
in ellipses that's also great this kind
of set of laws Newton's second law and
Newton's inverse square law for gravity
are much more powerful because they
don't simply work in idealized
situations where there's no other force
acting on it or whether you're just a
planet ignoring all the other
gravitational forces they work all the
time right this is supposed to be
absolutely everywhere absolutely
universal and we thought this for
hundreds of years we thought this was
right it got updated in the 20th century
with quantum mechanics and relativity
but this is a much more powerful
paradigm for thinking about physics so
let me try to exactly mention you know
just re mention what that paradigm
actually is we have some object there's
a planet it has some velocity okay V is
the velocity what is a velocity velocity
is the rate of change of the position so
you see
in just from the vocabulary that the
idea of rates of change is going to
become really important in this
discussion so you have a planet it has a
position it's located at some position X
again I'm ignoring vector signs and all
that craziness it's just some abstract
notion of position velocity tells you
how the position is changing Newton's
second law F equals MA tells you how the
velocity itself is changing okay so then
you're done if you know how the velocity
is changing you can know what the
velocity does over time and then you can
figure out what the position does over
time and then you have the complete
trajectory of the particle but what is
happening here conceptually is at one
moment of time at an instantaneous
moment in the history of the universe
you tell me the position of the particle
the velocity of the particle I'm using
particle in a generalized form so planet
counts as a particle here and then you
tell me what forces are acting on the
particle and you're done I can tell you
what's going to happen next and then I
can do that the next moment of time tell
you what's gonna happen next and I can
work that forward all the way to the
past or the future these are reversible
laws they go in either direction of time
that was the great insight of Pierce
ammonal applause when he invented
Laplace's demon so the paradigm here is
there exists something called the state
there exists okay little math notation
there there exists the state of the
particle of the object and that includes
not just the position but also the
velocity and it exists at one instant of
time and knowing the state of the
particle and the laws of physics you can
figure out everything you can figure out
what happens next from that everything
follows
because of course I said you also need
the forces on the particle but guess
what the forces are determined by the
states of the other objects in the
universe so if you know the states of
everything you can figure out the forces
between them and you're done now
actually Newton didn't do this
Newton didn't do what we're about to
explain when he wrote the Principia
Mathematica but I'm told I never read
the packet be a mathematical almost no
one has you know it's not really
traditional in physics to go back and
read the original papers of the great
people before us I'll confess I've never
read Einstein's original papers on
relativity even though I've written
textbook on relativity and physics the
idea is it's the ideas that matter not
their original presentation Newton's
original presentation of this stuff in
the in the Principia number one it was
in Latin it took a while for it to be
translated into English and number two
he was apparently afraid of using all of
the new mathematical techniques he
invented so he tried very hard to only
use existing mathematical techniques so
people would believe him so people would
accept it right away
Subramani and Chandrasekar who is a
great 20th century astrophysicist
actually wrote a version of the
principia mathematica for the common
reader if you ever want to know what
newton was actually up to in the in his
great masterwork the Principia
I would advise not buying either the
original Latin or English but buying
chandrasekar's explanation of what was
going on okay but what Newton did do in
addition to what he wrote in the
Principia was he figured out a very
general way of solving problems like
this by problems like this I mean
there's a state right now we're telling
you the rate of change of things and
from that you figure out everything so
notice what doesn't exist in this
picture I don't need to know the history
of the particle right I don't need to
know that it was moving on an ellipse I
don't need to know what formed it or
what started it I don't need to know
anything about the future okay there's
no teleology there's no goal toward
which it is stretching it is an
instantaneous set of knowledge right at
this moment of time is all I need
No so if you want you can sort of
conceptualize visually this picture by
imagining time going bottom to top so
you have one moment of time this is all
space and everything in it in one moment
of time you have some particles going
around in the universe and from the laws
of physics you can figure out what those
particles are going to be doing at every
moment in the future and they what they
were doing at every moment in the past
you don't need historical or future
information this is a an incredibly
powerful subtle move in physics just to
imagine that this is the paradigm we're
talking about okay but to do it to
actually turn this sort of conceptual
picture into results that we can then
test against observations we need some
mathematical tools and that is where
calculus comes in
so calculus is the mathematical
technique we have for dealing with rates
of change in their accumulation over
time so what do I mean by that
consider you know a car okay I do not
have any drawing skills so here's my
version of a car sorry about that you
have a car moving okay this is just
something we're familiar with these days
it has a position X and X changes over
time okay because the car moves you can
move it forward you can move it backward
we're just imagining a car moving down
one road in the single direction so you
don't need to worry about turning left
turning right that's when you would have
to invent vectors and all that stuff or
at least x and y and z etc here we just
have a single variable the position of
the car changing over time and you might
think that you know if you were to plot
this okay look at this check it out
trying to use the capabilities of Notes
Plus which is my drawing software here
so you have time I'm gonna I'm gonna
make time go left to right I'm gonna
make X go up it's a little weird right
because I just do the car moving left to
right for X but just you know follow
along with me here because this will
make the later discussion a little bit
simpler here is the path of the car over
time and generally it'll be a mess right
you'll do all sorts of things you might
you know stop for groceries might go
back you might just be on a joyride in
this weird example you for some reason
keep putting your car into reverse and
then forward and reverse and so forth
but this is what might be the path of
the car over time okay
X as a function of T this is what we
want to be able to figure out in
Newtonian physics paradigm we want to be
able to say okay where is the car how
fast is it moving what forces are acting
on it use all that information to solve
for the trajectory of the car over time
X as a function of time now you notice I
didn't mention the velocity in principle
the velocity is figure out a ball from
this information right in principle at
every moment of time there exists a
velocity if you're in your car you have
a speedometer okay the rate at which
your position is changing over time is
something that is known that is that is
determined anyway from this exact kind
of information the question is how do
you actually do it well it's hard like
right from there it's done it's not at
all obvious how you're supposed to
figure out what the velocity is velocity
is the rate of change of the position
but that's changing kind of wildly from
that let's let's point out something
that is maybe a little bit obvious but
will be helpful if you had a situation
where the car moved in a straight line
at a constant velocity if you had that
situation then it would be easy to
figure out what the velocity was so I'm
not telling you what the velocity is I'm
just saying what I know is that the
velocity is constant and I know X as a
function of time okay well all I have to
do then is figure out what the change in
X was what the change in T was this is X
there is t and in this very very simple
case where everything is moving at a
constant velocity the velocity is just
the distance you travel divided by the
time it took if you move at a constant
velocity so let me move that to get it
out of the way here for a second
so when the velocity is constant it's
just the change in distance over the
change in time this is a rewriting of
the fact that the distance you travel is
the velocity times the time when your
velocity is constant and therefore if
your velocity were greater on the
picture this would look like a larger
deviation right a larger slope of the
picture so this is a slow car and this
is a fast car low velocity high velocity
so in this simple world where the
velocity is constant in the simple
thought experiment example the velocity
is just the slope of this graph X versus
time the position versus time the
steeper the slope is the faster you're
moving the more distance you travel in a
certain amount of time oh my goodness I
completely screw that up didn't I you're
making fun of me there in the background
okay
this was obviously the time and that was
obviously the distance I'm gonna leave
that in just so we know that we all make
mistakes and also I don't want to do it
again okay so the more distance you
travel versus the shortest time the
higher your velocity is good the problem
is we're not usually moving at a
constant velocity we're usually doing
this kind of weird thing right where
you're sort of accelerating and
decelerating your velocity is changing
all the time what about that well you
might think that you could approximate
right you could approximate the velocity
like if I just did a straight line that
was a good approximation to the overall
curve then I could figure out the slope
of that straight line and call that my
average velocity or something like that
but I don't want to do that I want to be
more specific I want to get the actual
velocity at every moment of time so here
is the idea that Newton had in for an
arbitrary curve it might be going up and
down a lot it's nothing like the
straight line that we looked at okay
but let's just take a particular point
on this curve Newton's bright idea is
this you can zoom in that's it that's
the bright idea of course there's a lot
of mathematical details involved there
but look
I picked this way of explaining it
because on this program I can zoom in a
little bit okay if you look just at this
tiny little bit of the trajectory you
know between here and here it's almost
like a straight line you could draw a
pretty straight line between these two
points and then you could figure out the
slope of that and then you could repeat
that at every point along the curve you
could zoom in to that particular point
figure out what the approximate change
in the distance and the velocity was and
yeah the distance and the time was and
then you can figure out the velocity
from the slope of that now it seems like
it's only ever going to be an
approximation doing something like that
you know you could approximate a curve
by a straight line and the approximation
becomes better and better the more you
zoom in but it's always an approximation
right well that is in fact the
brilliance of calculus calculus is a way
of taking this approximation and making
it exact and the idea is taking what we
call the limit the limit is in this very
very casual way of talking apologies to
any real mathematicians out there but
this is what we're gonna get in this
video that the limit is a way of
infinitely zooming in it's basically a
way of saying sure if I just take two
points that are close by and draw a
straight line between them and calculate
the slope of that I will approximate the
curve but I know the slope but I know
that as those two points come closer and
closer the approximation becomes better
and better so therefore I can just say
well what would happen if I zoomed in
infinitely far if I take the limit of a
successive number of approximations the
curve looks more and more like a
straight line and I can just calculate
its slope that's what the idea of a
limit does it just zooms in infinitely
and I'm not gonna go into the
mathematical details here but Newton
figured them out like nits who was his
competitor also figured them out for
reasons that I do not understand it was
conventional back in those days to get
brilliant scientific or mathematical
results and then not tell anybody right
like to put them in code or something
like that
quite the opposite of our current
paradigm that we have but anyway newton
and leibniz both figured out a way of
doing this so so basically I mean
basically that's it that's what I want
to say I'm not gonna go into any of the
details Newton figured out a way to
figure out the change the rate of change
of position versus time and using a
mathematical technique of infinitely
zooming in of taking the limit that was
the origin of calculus let me say an
alternative way of saying the same thing
so I said that if the line was just a
straight line other words if it were
constant velocity then you can calculate
the slope then it's very very easy to do
here's another way of thinking about
sort of the same basic technique the
same basic philosophy what if time were
not continuous okay so we had you know
time here x over here and we had this
curve that was sort of waving back and
forth in this smooth continuous way what
if time were just not continuous what if
the only times that existed were a
discrete set of moments at different
intervals okay then you wouldn't need
calculus you wouldn't need limits you
would need anything like that all you
would have to do is sort of at any one
time if you know X at the next time you
know X so you know X at time one X at
time two X at time three X at time four
you could just calculate the slope
because it's a straight line so we know
how to calculate the slope of a straight
line it's just the change in X over the
change in time right so then you could
do it but we think that time is not
continuous okay but there is a sense in
which as this imaginary discretization
of time becomes more and more finely
grained as the moments in which we allow
time to exist get closer and closer
together this piecewise constant curve
becomes more and more like the smooth
curve that we actually think we have in
the real world so what we do here is we
call this little tiny change in time
delta T
change Delta Greek letter Delta means
changed physicists and this little tiny
change in X Delta X and then what we say
is for constant velocity we know that
velocity is just the distance you travel
over the time for discrete time the
velocity can change but at every moment
at every little interval in this
discrete set of moments the velocity is
Delta x over delta T and the velocity
will change discontinuously at every
moment
so what newton and leibniz figure out a
way to do is for continuous time they
figured out a mathematical way of taking
these time intervals to be literally
zero to be infinitesimal and what they
write is V equals DX DT and they call
this the derivative and it's based on
the idea of infinitesimals in because
you have to work hard at this right I
mean you can take the limit as the time
gets the the discretization of time gets
smaller and smaller and smaller so delta
T gets smaller and smaller and smaller
but as that happens guess what Delta X
also gets smaller and smaller and
smaller so DX and DT are supposed to be
roughly speaking and again huge polities
any real mathematicians out there but
roughly speaking this is the
infinitesimal change in position versus
an infinitesimal change in time so in
some sense this is 0/0 because in an
infant Hezbollah mount of time you don't
move at all okay but by taking the limit
you can resolve the fact that 0/0
doesn't really exist so I'm gonna erase
this just because it's sort of bad form
to have it there basically you can think
of this infinitesimals this idea of
limits as making sense of 0/0 in this
particular case so that's what newton
and leibniz did they figured out a way
to take crazy curves like this if
someone gave you the explicit form you
know X of T equals the cosine of T or
something like that there's a set of
tool there's a mathematical toolbox for
figuring out what the velocity is for as
we say in the lingo for taking the
derivative of that curve over time good
there's a couple more things I need to
mention before your knowledge of
calculus is more or less complete up to
some mathematical niceties I'm not going
to tell you how to actually calculate
any derivatives or anything like that
but that's the brilliance that's the fun
that's the joy of doing calculus so you
totally should do it if you haven't done
it already the other thing is that you
can go backwards in other words remember
why are we doing this we're doing this
because we are given a law of nature F
equals MA forces mass times acceleration
we know what the force is okay so we can
figure out what the acceleration is we
want to use the acceleration to get the
velocity and then use the velocity to
get the position what I just talked on
to you was how to use the position as a
function of time to get the velocity you
take the derivative but we want to go
backwards if we were given the velocity
over time could we figure out what the
position was over time I'm checking now
that Caliban has not actually messed up
with my green screen again if the green
screen is varying that's because there's
a kitty out there playing with it but he
seems to be peaceful right now so
Caliban let us know if you want to to
appear and this Caliban would appear in
the video all right
Caliban does not know much about
calculus he doesn't really like videos
but he's a good cat
okay leave our green screen alone
Caliban
so what Newton figured out is that you
can in fact go backwards if to go from
position as a function of time to
velocity is taking the derivative going
from velocity as a function of time to
position is called taking the integral
and basically we can think about the
integral as being the area under a curve
so let's say that instead of being given
the position as a function of time we
were given the velocity as a function of
time okay it's a different curve now
right it's not position versus a
function times velocity now and we have
some velocity who knows where we got it
from maybe it's the readout of your
speedometer over time that can happen
how do we figure out what the position
was what the func what the analogous
function of X versus T is so what Newton
and Leibniz figured out is well at every
moment again this is going to be a story
of limits and infinitesimals at every
moment we know that the change in
position if we did it in discrete terms
is the velocity times the change in time
and in the limit this becomes DX is V
times DT so what X is is changing by an
amount which we call V that's what V is
supposed to be it's the rate of change
of X so when V is large X is changing by
a lot when V is small X is changing by
little when V is negative x is
decreasing okay that's how velocities
work so basically we could imagine
taking a little segment here again as if
we were discretizing time and this area
under that curve tells us the amount by
which the position has changed when the
curve is very tall the position has
changed by a lot and the area under that
curve is a lot when the velocity is very
low is only changed by a little bit so
the new problem that we have is not
taking the slope of a curve
it's taking the area under the curve but
guess what the same philosophy kind of
works if you imagine breaking up time
and two discrete moments okay then you
can figure out the area under one of
these little skinny rectangles is just V
times delta T if it's a discreet a
little bit that's the area of this
rectangle right here when the velocity
is large as a big area when it's small
it's a small one and then you add them
all up okay so you say that X as a
function of time is just the sum this is
the Greek Sigma the letter for sum of
all the velocities at one time times
delta T and in calculus language this
becomes the integral sign V of T DT
again you're not supposed to remember
what all these symbols mean it's just
because you will sometimes see them in
the real world this is what they are
this big integral sign kind of is
supposed to represent or resemble the
letter S just like this Sigma the Greek
letter Sigma is the Greek letter that
corresponds to s so s is for some it's
the sum of all these little bits the
integral is a way of summing up all the
little contributions of the change in
velocity to figure out what the position
is and you can do exactly the same thing
for acceleration Newton says that F
equals MA acceleration is the change in
the velocity over time so the velocity
over time is the integral of the
acceleration at any one time times a
little tiny infinitesimal amount of time
being passed so if you know what the
acceleration is you can use this formula
to figure out the velocity if you know
what the velocity is you can use the
formula above to figure out the position
and then you know everything that is
exactly the point and the brilliant
thing the really wonderful thing is they
are inverses of each other integration
and differentiation so let me see if I
said this the derivative
of the integral of some function f as a
function of time I write f here because
it could be the velocity or the
acceleration the position doesn't matter
equals the original function derivatives
and integrals are inverses of each other
the area under the curve where the curve
is defined by the accumulation of
something the velocity or whatever the
slope of the that area curve is the
original function that's what this says
this is the fundamental theorem of
calculus now despite this wonderful
symmetry derivatives are the inverses of
integrals the truth is that it's much
easier in practice to do derivatives to
take the derivative of a function than
to take an integral of the function
differentiating things is more or less
trivial in fact for almost all
interesting functions whereas
integrating can obviously be very
conveniently extremely hard if you take
a calculus class you're going to spend a
lot of time doing integrals as your
homework problem so let me close with
one last philosophical point in some
sense we drew this picture of the
paradigm right time going up different
particles at different positions in
space all you need to know is that that
one moment of time and then you can go
forward and backward as far as we know
physics does work like this okay we
change the rules of Newtonian mechanics
in the 20th century we had quantum
mechanics and we had relativity that
changed Newtonian mechanics in important
ways but this idea this sort of
laplacian paradigm that you tell me
everything that's going on at one moment
of time I can predict the future in the
past still seems to be in place we're
not absolutely sure
in fact the measurement problem of
quantum mechanics which we'll get to
later is an example of something where
it doesn't seem to be the case that you
can predict the future from the present
but that may or may not just be apparent
and maybe we just don't have enough
information we honestly don't know but
this still seems to be the basic picture
but we can
imagine ways in which it might be wrong
right because as I said at the end of
the last video we're supposed to be open
to changing our ideas about physics
that's what makes physics great as it's
never done we're never finished we're
not finished yet anyway so could this
idea be wrong I mean one of the most
obvious things in the world is to
imagine the time and maybe space and
maybe everything else actually is not
continuous right
once Newton and his contemporaries
introduced the idea of limits and the
idea of calculus into the mathematical
vocabulary it became very controversial
right it was not at all clear that this
was sensible math that was going on and
it turns out that you learn a lot of
interesting things so for example you
know here's our time line okay and let's
say this is time equals zero time equals
1 etc time equals 2 here's one of the
interesting things about infinity how
many numbers are there between zero and
one well you know there's a half there's
a third etc there's a lot of numbers
there's clearly a very large number in
fact there's pretty clearly an infinite
number of numbers right like if you give
me any two numbers if you pick out any
two locations on the number line I can
find lots of numbers in between them
that's a little tiny proof that there
should be an infinite number of numbers
between 0 & 1 but you can do better in
fact the number of numbers between 0 & 1
mathematicians later showed Georg
contour among them is equal to the
number of numbers between minus infinity
and plus infinity so if you take the
interval from zero to one and you add to
it the interval between 1 & 2 and the
interval between 2 & 3 etc and all the
intervals to the other side you would
think you're adding more numbers the
number of numbers would go up that is
not how it works the number of numbers
between 0 & 1 is infinitely big and is
the same size infinity as the number of
numbers between minus infinity and
infinity this is a fairly mild and not
very bothersome fact about infinity but
once you really get into it there's a
lot of facts about infinity that give
people the heebie-jeebies that then rub
people the wrong way so there's a very
strong impulse to say well maybe time is
actually discrete in the real world so
maybe all this calculus stuff isn't even
really necessary okay in fact when we
solve equations you know when you want
to put a rocket on the moon or send a
probe to Mars or something like that
right you do solve Newton's laws of
motion and Newton's law of gravity but
you put them on a computer and computers
in the modern age are mostly digital
computers so what do they do they
discretize they approximate the motion
of the thing by looking at time as if it
were actually and really cut up into
discrete sets of instances of moments of
time and that's a perfectly good
approximation as long as your time
interval is really really short so how
would we ever know if time really were
discrete rather than continuous well
there are certain arguments that say
that it really is continuous symmetry
arguments and so forth but the real
answer is we don't know yet this
calculus stuff is convenient it's
helpful it's very very useful you'll see
it all over the place derivatives and
integrals but we don't know it's the way
the world really works maybe someday
we'll figure that out